друзі всім привіт з поїзда
під'їжджаю до львова б зустріч делегацій
прованської асамблеї ради Європи
хочу вам розповісти про те, що ж там
відбувається за поребриком пекло друзі
паніка вже істерика в Білгородській
області риють окопи можете собі зараз
розповім детальніше а ви підписуйтесь
на канал щоб нічого не пропустити нас
вже 500
52000 величезна армія диктори знають
правду та правду поширюють і так що
сталося Білгородська область і ви
пам'ятайте нещодавно там спочатку цей і
невдало підкорив на складі боєприпасів та
він вибухнув потім хтось зовсім
невдало по краю можеш перед цим
чорнобаєв сходив на складі пального і він
вибухнув і тому що вибухнув там
показувати якісь гелікоптери летять
начебто вони бомбять нафтобазу, адже шлях уже
розповідав, що україна більше немає
авіація не вертольотів нічого тому
диво напевно це власне сталося у
загалом знову щось вибухнуло після
цього дива вище а значить записав нещодавно
відео
глава одного з районів
білгородської області дивіться на цього
клоуна начепилося а букву z у нацистську
і розповідає за рахунок що а я і
готуємося роєм окопи послухати шановні
друзі всім добрий вечір
читаю ваше повідомлення читаю ваші
коментарі та розуміє що сьогодні
викликає занепокоєння
проведення земляних робіт на території
нашого муніципалітету перевірки це
нашим з вами прохання я як людина
військовий завжди перестрахування і
сьогодні я вас запевняю що
безпеки нашої території як і
раніше нічого не загрожує давайте ми це
приймемо як треба і разом з вами
зберегти спокій так влаштувати
окопів і що кира сильна армія ви ж не
розповідали що всіх навпаки
переможець якщо ви прийдете від виродки
щоб ви відчули тепер що таке
війна ви тільки починаєте війну ви
завжди повинні знати просвітити історію
що вона прийде до вас на землю, а тепер
вони вже там фані герой від їхнього досвіду на і
кеш та cookies z
мізках у них одна звивина мабуть спокій
за такий знайти все від вуха до вуха так
проходить
інший голова району в Білгородській
області
він вийшов із попросив не користуватися
людей феєрверки чому б раптом зазвичай
люди бояться вибухів, а ви вже вибухів
боїтеся тобто ви вже розумієте що
вибухи і у вас можуть і вибухи ви боїтеся
тільки початок це тільки початок
нахилів там багато за поребриком ще не
клон це знаменитий дон дон дон дон
кадиров та його tick tock воїнство
журналістам я вже не раз викривав
фейки його але ось нової фейки приспіли
знали всі кошти інфо проаналізували
його відео яке він викладає нібито
його бійців страшних жахливо із штанів валя
з'ясувалося що всі 9-ту знято до будинку
сквері в одному сквері sperry козацтва
в лівобережному районі морю і
найближче до власне кажучи до Росії
та не зрозуміло і зайшли легше
всього його там вони всі ти знімаються і
мега постановочні відео і все і куди
далі всі ці розповіді про те, що вони
там цього та в центрі щось там
захоплює все це друзі теж зрозуміло
що все дуже важко у маріуполі зрозуміло
що наші там напевно тримається реально
з останніх сил але ніякого як вони
показуєш не там ходять і щось
знімають це досі розповім вам fake
fake сама справжня але ще пішла значить
інформації те що кадировці означає там
фейками займалися і з безпілотниками
нібито вміє ними користуватися та вони
виклали відео як вони користуються
безпілотники подивіться на це сир
[музика]
просто як мавпи себе краще щось тикають
мавпи дали граната дали безпілотник
погратися
п'ятикласники легше розберуться і внеся
ведуть чим ці хіти дикі, яких він
витяг і розповідає все-таки це мега
воїв друзі ось такі новини за
поребрик всім привіт від вас передам
привіт славному місця лову завтра
повертаюся пік тримаємо лад